Welcome back to Computer Vision.
We're going to continue with our
conversation about segmentation.
And this time we're
going to up a little bit,
the sophistication of some of
the methods that we're talking about.
So far, all of our segmentation
work has really talked about
sort of clustering pixels
within some feature space.
That is sort of describing each of the
pixels so i might build the clusters in
position, and and intensity or position
in color, or even in a texture space.
What we didn't really do was talk about
the connection between one pixel and
another.
Right, I mean after all if you're doing
a segmentation the idea is that you're
going to be drawing a boundary and
you're going to say nope you,
you go to the left you,
you go to the right.
So I, want to talk about
the connection between pixels.